louis burton 31 ans originaire de
rambouillet s'est élancé pour le vendée
globe le 6 novembre dernier
le marin a pris le départ de cette
compétition de plus les sables d'olonne
aborde son imoca bureau vallée en
compagnie de 28 autres skippers ça fait
trois jours qu'on est parti tout pile et
on avait pris un bon départ on était
bien positionné là pour la première nuit
à la taille du cap finistère
et puis petit souci technique sans
gravité mais qui ont pris pas mal de
temps vous faut faire une deuxième nuit
pas top
après un mois de course ses proches lui
manque dans ce tour du monde en
solitaire et sans escale le navigateur
communique avec eux en envoyant des
dizaines de mails par jour et des vidéos
tout va bien le bateau va vite moi je
suis en pleine forme
vous me manquez beaucoup beaucoup
j'arrête pas de regarder des photos et
je vais mettre une petite chanson
ça
il veut
toujours droit de
début décembre le skipper est ancré à la
11e place mais le navigateur ne fait pas
la course seul des baleines sont venus
lui tenir compagnie pendant son périple
au large de l'australie
une balade une baleine sur quoi
aussi proche
après 87 jours de course lui burton est
de retour au port des sables d'olonne
au classement le navigateur termine
finalement septième de cette huitième
édition
pas vraiment mon temps décrassage je
m'attendais à ça on m'avait dit que ça
serait très fort et surtout c'est de
voir autant de monde autant de monde
d'un coup au bout de trois mois de
solitude c'est un vrai vrai vrai bonheur
en fait le marin devrait participer à
une troisième édition du vendée globe
avec un bateau équipé des dernières
technologies
de quoi cette fois-ci rivaliser que les
premiers du classement
[Musique]